I have a very interesting idea but it's
it's a super complex move
it's one of those moves that could end
up being a mistake
but I don't think it is
yeah this is such an interesting
position honestly so rich
such a rich position
I could think about this for 30 minutes
honestly this position's so interesting
and we'll we'll unlock some of the
secrets after the game I'm excited for
this
[Music]
we are white against Avella vastida
all right let's go E4
as we usually do
um
we are once again facing a Karo Khan you
know what that means we get to play the
Fantasy again
and we already have had the fantasy
twice in the speedrun we've done a lot
of theoretical work in the fantasy so by
now if you've watched the speed run
diligently you should have a good sense
of how to play the Fantasy if I remember
correctly both of our previous opponents
they took on e4 and then they both made
the same mistake with Knight to F6 kind
of an alkyne Karo Khan cross
this time we are facing a new move
Knight to D7 and I will admit I've never
seen this move this is not considered a
top theoretical move it's it's what I
would call an inaccuracy now obviously a
move like this cannot be a huge mistake
it's a developing move but it's a weird
developing move I mean it's a passive
developing move and black is not in any
way challenging our control of the
center essentially black is giving us
the kind of position that we want
and black is going to get most likely a
very solid but incredibly passive setup
as a result now we have I would say two
main choices here with white we can
close the center immediately
by playing E4 E5
and then how are such moves often
followed up well if you play the French
with white then you might know that E5
is often followed up with F4 and then
you bring your knight out to F3 and then
you can further solidify your Center by
playing uh C3
and that does seem incredibly like an
incredibly good version of of the French
structure and I'll show you after the
game
what exactly I mean when I say French
structure like if you're not a knight C3
French player with why you might become
confused when I refer to the French
structure but you'll see what I mean so
I really like E5 here I think E5 is the
is the the way to try to punish black
for this move the other option of course
is to play Knight C3 just a typical
developing move
but after Knight C3 when it bothers me a
little bit is the prospect of black
taking on e4 and then striking at the
center with E5 which leads to some very
concrete play that I'm not sure is
entirely palatable to us especially
given the presence of the alternative E5
so I like closing it down I also don't
think we've had too many of these closed
positions in the speedrun and I kind of
want to give you a broad overview of how
to play different types of positions and
of course as we all know a lot of
players they struggle with positions
that involve a closed Center they feel
like they don't know what plans to
pursue and when the center is closed
it's very easy to feel as though you're
just kind of shuffling your pieces
aimlessly back and forth hopefully this
game will kind of change your mind in
that regard close Center positions can
actually be some of the most interesting
that you get in chess because they force
you to play on the flanks but flank play
can be some of the most beautiful and
tactical uh that you see in in any chess
positions
so what are our next couple of moves
going to be well most likely we're going
to solidify both
wrongs of our Pawn chain right I'm
struggling to figure out a way to refer
to like these pawns individually we have
a pawn chain right on D4 and E5 so both
Links of the pawn chain we are going to
solidify with other pawns to make it as
robust as possible why do we need to
make it robust because black is likely
to attack our Pawn chain with uh his own
pawns right so for example in the French
you often see the move C5 in fact black
may play this move right now that is why
we need C3
black could also attack the pawn chain
from the other end with the move F6 you
also see that often in the French and
that's why I like playing F4
so C5 is on the board this is
essentially a no-brainer we play C3 we
most certainly do not want our Pawn
chain to dissolve this early in the game
because we don't have any pieces
developed and the only thing standing
between us and like death is our Pawn
chain in the center
so we definitely want to go C3
you might wonder well isn't E5 already
well defended it is there is a second
reason that we want to play F4 and that
is of course to open up the natural
developing Square for the G1 Knight
and the reason we want to develop the
Knight to F3 is that it has no other
good spots to go if instead we had
developed the Knight to E2 that would
just be incredibly awkward and it would
also close off the natural development
of the bishop
Queen C7 is a bit of an odd move I don't
think it accomplishes that much notice
that it does not really threaten C takes
D4 because we can take back and the
bishop on C1 is is protected by our
Queen
so I think we can continue developing
along the lines that I have outlined and
do it from several different orders we
can play Bishop to D3 first if you want
to prioritize peace development
or we can immediately play F4 and then
bring our Knight out to F3 I like both
options
I generally lean toward peace
development first when possible
especially because
we are technically lagging in
development we haven't developed any
minor pieces yet so I do like the
possibility of bringing our Bishop out
first
and we're also opening up the further
possibility of playing Knight G1 to E2
which I just mentioned is an awkward
move but with the bishop already outside
of the outside of its initial Square 92
becomes a little bit more appealing to
me
we're trying to play as flexibly as
possible given that our opponent isn't
developing into ambitious style we're
leaving open many developmental
possibilities and I largely think this
is a matter of taste I like the look of
knights you want to eat to if you want
to prioritize rapid development that's
the way to do it but if you want to play
in a maximally ambitious style and get
as much space as possible then we should
go for my initial idea and play F4
but F4 is the more textbook approach to
these types of positions so we're going
to go for F4 this is the more kind of I
want to take it to my opponent type of
move
and I think when a lot of people see
this move what you'll notice is that the
bishop on C1 starts complaining like hey
what about me now I'm staring at my own
Pawn but the bishop has plenty of space
to develop to E3 or even to D2 and this
is where I quote my phrase about not
every piece
you know having to climb Mount Everest
at one time Bishop to E3 is an entirely
serviceable way of developing the bishop
in fact on E3 the bishop does a great
job supporting the pawn chain even
further and we definitely want our Pawn
chain to be incredibly robust but we'll
cross that bridge when we get there
let's start with Knight F3 let's get our
pieces out first the ones that we know
where to go
yeah or distribute the coveted vaccine
Knight to F5 Knight E7
so if you know anything about the French
then you know that usually this night in
the French travels to F5 where it puts
pressure of course on the D4 Pawn
so you might be tempted by the idea of
G4 but G4 is way too Cavalier we haven't
developed enough pieces to justify a
move like that and G4 is very bad
because of H5 classic positional move
and
funnily enough the opposite effect is
reached we play G4 to cover the F5
square but as a result black gets a huge
outpost on F5 because after G4 H5 we
cannot play H3 that's the big problem
black takes on G4 and you often see this
on the other side of the board where the
Rook on H1 is going to be hanging
so instead
we have again two options we can Castle
kingside or we can preemptively get our
Bishop to E3 but what and what I like
about that move
is that in response to Knight F5 our
Bishop can very nicely slide back to F2
and I like that because if we instead
castle and black plays Knight F5 our
Bishop suddenly can't come out to E3
anymore is that the end of the world
absolutely not in fact in that position
G4 becomes a lot more appealing because
it comes with Tempo but these minor
subtleties these minor developmental
details often make a huge difference on
the course of the game without you even
realizing it so let's go Bishop E3
and Knight F5 we drop our Bishop back to
F2
and later that Bishop from F2 is first
of all serving a very important purpose
of overprotecting the D4 pawn and indeed
that is what happens but also much much
later that Bishop has a weight toward
infiltrating Black's position Bishop H4
and Bishop F6 is a maneuver that you see
quite often especially if Blackfin
ghetto is their Bishop on G7
okay now we continue developing we
Castle
yeah so the move H5 again is typical for
these structures and I've used that
phrase a lot typical for these
structures because we do have a very
typical type of French structure where
our opponent is displaying knowledge of
the sort of classic ideas and the
classic way to arrange the pawns but H5
isn't all hunky-dory black is preventing
G4 that is true but black is creating
major weaknesses as some of you are
pointing out along the dark squares in
particular notice that we have an
outpost on G5 doesn't mean that we
should play Knight G5 here we shouldn't
Knight G5 allows black to trade and fill
some of the holes but later on that G5
could be an important Transit point when
we start attacking the black king
the other thing that we can do later on
is take the Knight out of the equation
and then stick our dark squared Bishop
on H4 as I indicated earlier that could
allow us to control all of the dark
squares on the king side
with our Queen so an idea that you see
is actually Queen D1 to E1 then the
trade on F5 and then Bishop H4
and after the trade our Queen on H4 will
have access to a lot of these juicy
outposts on the king side
but we're jumping the gun here because
we haven't completed our development and
with a center closed the one major like
rule about positions with a closed
Center is that you can generally take
more time to do stuff than you would
with the center open and that makes
intuitive sense right that the position
doesn't change that quickly when the
sender is completely closed especially
when it's as well defended as our Center
is
so Knight A3 is a bit of a dead end move
after A6 yeah you could be tempted by
this maneuver 93 Knight P5 but I don't
like it because Knight A3 A6 like where
is the Knight gonna go I think a more
robust way of developing here is and B
to D2 toward the center and you might
say well where is the Knight going from
D2 again nowhere nowhere yet but it is
in the center
and you never know when its services
could be required
it's a Frankfurt airport move that's
exactly right
the other thing to remember about closed
Center positions is that broadly
speaking there are two types of plans
there's a type of plan where we attempt
to position our pieces in a certain way
and then rip the center open blast it
open and our hope in such a scenario is
that we have arranged our pieces in a
better way than our opponent has in
order to prepare for the opening of the
center like we prepare our pieces in
such a way that when the Center opens up
we are somehow better equipped to handle
the consequences than our opponent is
and one reason that may be the case is
if we have a big development advantage
or if our pieces are placed a lot more
actively when the center is closed the
difference in peace activity may not be
all that felt right because things are
closed up and just the fact that a piece
is not very well developed might not be
imminently felt but when the Center
opens you suddenly start realizing that
all of those disparities in piece
activity are actually important and we
in this very position with the white
pieces have a very interesting idea
that is part of this category of plan
where we just blast the entire thing
open and we hope that our more active
pieces are going to be better equipped
in the resulting chaos
to you know address the new problems of
the position what am I thinking about
what does it even mean here to open up
the center well what I'm not talking
about is dtake C5 that isn't that isn't
really open the center because DC
actually just gives black a little bit
more space and it allows black to
contest the dark squares in the center
particularly the E3 Square
instead I'm thinking not about B4 B4
black can keep things closed with C4 but
instead about the move C4 ourselves
creating the pawn box and by creating
the pawn box we are guaranteeing that
one way or the other the center is going
to open
but we can play C4 immediately
what we can also do is eliminate Black's
only active piece before playing C4
we can eliminate Black's only active
piece and then go C4 and really try to
pin our hopes in the resulting position
on our incredibly active pieces
so Bishop takes F5 is what I'm thinking
about but I also really like the look of
C4
because we can delay Bishop takes F5 we
don't have to play it immediately we can
play it a little later
yeah I actually like the look of C4
and if black plays Pawn takes D4 then we
can take the Knight on F5
you might look at this and think two
things first of all what about Knight
takes D4 yeah Knight takes D4 is what I
was evaluating just now
and hopefully that'll happen so I can
show you my considerations I'm not
positive by the way that C4 is the
correct move not at all I have a feeling
that it is but this is a largely
intuitive determination I didn't do too
much calculation here the second thought
that you might be having is how do I
know that we're not afraid of losing B2
well first of all losing B2 is almost
never a problem when your Castle to the
other side of the board
right unless you lose a bunch of other
pawns when black takes B2 and I'm sure
you've blundered like that before right
where you blunder B2 but then you also
lose C3 so you don't just lose one Pawn
you lose your whole Queen side here our
Queen side is still very much intact
it's not like black has anything to do
with our Pawn Cube by taking on B2 Queen
takes B2 creates no threats allows us to
consider to continue pursuing our agenda
in the center
and I'm gonna have to prove it Queen
takes me two on the board
okay let me think for a second
I have a very interesting idea but it's
it's a super complex move
it's one of those moves that could end
up being a mistake
but I don't think it is
yeah this is such an interesting
position honestly so rich
such a rich position
I could think about this for 30 minutes
honestly this position's so interesting
and we'll we'll unlock some of the
secrets after the game I'm excited for
this
let me share my idea with y'all
um honestly this is probably a mistake
oh this I think I know why it might be a
mistake actually
wow incredible black is an incredible
response to the move I was intending
which by the way is Queen to A4 trying
to get the other Rook to B1 in order to
trap the queen
but that is far from the only way in
which we can address this position we
don't need to try to trap the queen I
think the queen is untrappable here we
don't have enough Firepower on the queen
side so I think we should instead
continue our focus in the center
and continue trying to blast the center
open so that we can exploit our
increased peace activity
so let's start
by making a move that we know is going
to be good
we know this move is going to be good
C takes D5 right we need to open up the
center in order to do that that is why
we played the move C4
and now we take on D5 now if black does
not recapture then we can drive this
Pawn forward to D6
and that looks horrific for black
absolutely horrific
so
black will probably end up taking back
on D5 and we're going to have to speed
up a little bit here we've got six
minutes so I'm gonna have to make a
couple moves likely without too much
explanation
so what to do after e takes D5 is the
big question
well most of you should be tempted by
the prospect of then taking the Knight
on F5 ruining black structure even
further and as I said earlier
eliminating Black's only active piece
which right now is the Knight on F5
so you should be tempted positionally by
the move Bishop takes F5 of course
giving away your control over the light
squares is a little bit painful but it
might be a worthy price to pay
and I think it is a worthy price to pay
and I think that we should in fact take
the Knight while we still have a chance
and now we should complete the opening
of the center
we should complete the opening of the
center by playing DC
okay so we played CD then we took the
Knight now we play DC and now we can say
that the center is fully open which
means we need to start looking for
tactics right we need to transition from
General positional thinking where we can
you know luxuriously bring our pieces
out
and play a little bit more slowly now
the center is wide open moreover black
has not yet developed their Queen side
so we really need to step on the gas
pedal here because only a couple of
moves is what stands between black and
full consolidation of his extra Pawn
we're which let's not forget we have
given away we've given away a pawn
so there's a couple of moves that I
think are pretty good here
the move that I that occurs to me
intuitively perhaps it also occurs to
you intuitively is Bishop F2 to D4
because what I'm seeing there is that
we're actually x-raying The Rook so
Bishop D4 followed by E6 looks really
really interesting as a discovery
against that Rook further trying to
blast open the center but Bishop D4 is
also good as a standalone move it just
brings the bishop into the center and
that's just a priori a good thing
so
I'm a simple player I identify something
I like and we play it also we're down to
six minutes so we gotta play a little
bit faster here
so Bishop D4 it hits the queen also the
queen was starting to annoy me a little
bit it was
hindering our ability to bring pieces to
good squares right that Queen on B2
def it stops Queen C2 right it it just
sort of hangs over us so let's get it
out of there
so our opponent is thinking about where
to put their Queen
but our response to most moves is is
going to be E6
right there's a lot of ideas and one of
the challenging things about surviving
these positions I think our opponent is
playing this fantastically by the way so
far
making us work work to prove it
the thing is if we do not go E6 then
black is gonna stick a knight on E6 and
somehow keep the center close so E6 at
this point is pretty automatic and that
I think was a big mistake that right
there I think might be the decisive
mistake because this allows us and I'm
going to play this move without thinking
to take on F7 and drive the king out
into the open and once the king is on F7
we definitely have the Firepower to
exploit that
F6 was the only move there to survive
this is going to be destruction I think
all right
so there's two moves here that I like
most of you are probably tempted by
Knight to E5 check that's one of them 95
King E8 Queen takes H5 Chuck might seem
like mate but it's not it's not
Checkmate yet the king escapes to d8
and in that resulting position
unfortunately the move Queen to F7
which would have forked The Rook in the
pawn runs into Bishop E6
still not over
there's another move in this position
which is interesting Knight to G5 check
which leads to kind of a variation of
that line
but Knight G5 check allows the
additional resource King to G6 trying to
use the king itself as a Defender we've
talked about that Concept in a previous
speedrun I still think white is a huge
attack there but there's no reason for
us to over complicate things let's go
Knight E5
absolutely no reason for us to do
anything
outlandishly fancy
okay whoa this looks
totally
harakiri
and again I don't see a need for us here
to reinvent the wheel the one Pitfall I
think is the move rookie one which
perhaps a lot of you are looking at and
salivating at its prospects but remember
rookie one there's Knight C5 to E4
when you occupy an open file
you can't assume that black is just
going to move the King by the way King
D6 everybody should see that Knight C4
is a fork against the queen and the King
anytime the king and the queen are in a
forkable spot you have to think about
that so there's no need for us to do
anything of that nature I think the
simplest move is Queen takes Pawn not
because we win the pawn back that's not
the reason but because we're trying to
get the queen to F7 that is the reason
it just happens to capture the pawn we
would have played that move even if it
had not captured upon
okay
so we still have some work to do
Rook f8 was actually a very good move
which makes our job harder
now Queen G6 check has to be calculated
first and foremost Bishop F6
and then let me think for a second
can we find a Crusher in that position
it's not as easy as it appears
yeah I do like Knight G6 that's my
second candidate move
I love the look of Knight G6 because it
opens up the e-file and it targets an
important Cog in Black's defensive
machine that Bishop on E7 is handling a
lot of the dark squares which otherwise
would be ours for the taking
so Queen H6 check is tempting but there
is Rook to F6 that's an issue and maybe
in that position we could drive the
queen I don't know up to G7 and then
Queen G8 is a Checkmate threat
that does look winning that looks like a
excellent way to play by the way
oh I love it Queen H6 check because the
idea is to prevent Bishop F6
incredible
I love it let's do it Queen H6 check
comparing checks one of the themes of
this move
not assuming that two similar looking
checks do the same thing Bishop F6 here
of course gives up The Rook on f8
the King has nowhere to go
and what is the purpose of driving The
Rook out to F6 well there are two of
them the first is that the Rook is under
the X-ray of the bishop and don't forget
that even when you're attacking the king
you are very much allowed to win
material I I tell this a lot to students
there's a fixation when people are
attacking on trying to Checkmate the
king
and you might think well that's the only
way that the attack is going to succeed
but there's a whole category of ideas
that involve basically using the
weakness of your opponent's king in
order to win a decisive amount of
material when you're attacking you can
just go for your opponent's pieces
sometimes
and because your opponent is so
preoccupied with defending their King
he has to put pieces on vulnerable
squares that's why these combinations
happen
Queen B4
that's a good move
that's the only move I think
to keep things relatively protected
okay let me think for a second
Queen GHA King D6
I'm sure we have some sort of a
a beautiful win
okay Knight F3 I like a lot yeah I like
the look of Knight F3
we do have three minutes so we have to
be a little bit Speedy here
I love the look of Knight F3
because it doesn't give away any
advantages
it doesn't give away any advantages in
fact It prepares Knight G5
and it protects the bishop in a very
safe way
so the other thing to remember when
you've got these types of positions and
of course like a very resilient Defender
is going to make you work for every
little bit of the attack but among most
levels your opponent's going to collapse
in a matter of a couple of moves
what you have to remember is that we
haven't actually sacrificed anything
black just resigns it's plus 11 in this
position we haven't actually sacrificed
anything and what I wanted to show was
that if black plays a move like Knight
to E4
in order to take this thing out of
Knight G5 the top computer move is
actually an incredibly quiet move that
just brings a piece into the attack
that's all this move does
it also cuts off the king from its
potential Escape Route just to move okay
to C1 these are the types of moves that
a lot of people are not willing to make
when they're attacking and yet they make
all of the difference between a win and
a loss in many cases successful attack
failed attack
for instance Bishop D7 we just go Rook
to C7 and the added presence of The Rook
overwhelms Black's defensive abilities
here the top engine move is actually
Knight F7
with Queen to E5 checkmate
pretty little con concept there
everything's protected and this is
completely one-sided
so I've already presented a little bit
of fantasy theory in previous videos
um here we're just going to focus on our
opponent's move because I've never seen
it before and I really want to make sure
that we responded appropriately and I
think we did
so E5 is the first big decision of the
game E5
once again the reason I rejected Knight
C3 was because d e f e and E5 kind of
transposes into
a more conventional position and I
wanted to punish black for playing
Knight t7
according to the engine after d e white
is a little bit better here but how lame
would it have been to go into an end
game this quickly in the fantasy
you can play like Bishop E3
and then long castle and yeah white is
pretty comfortable here but black is a
nice night on E5 so I'm far from
convinced at this at this idea
so I think we played correctly I think
E5 is the way to punish Knight to D7
now
I kept repeating the term french
structure what I mean is a structure
that primarily occurs in two different
variations of the French defense one is
the advanced French this is the classic
E5 C5 and C3 and you get the pawn chain
from the game except you get a much
improved version for black this is a
better version than what black had in
the game because the Knight goes out to
C6 it doesn't go out to D7 which is a
terrible Square it's a dead end Square
the Knight has to go out to C6 here then
black puts immediate pressure on the D4
Pawn you can see how different this is
from the game continuation and white
isn't able to squeeze out squeeze in F4
this is what I meant there's also a line
of the French Knight C3 called the win
hour Bishop B4 and a kind of similar
structure arises in the main line of the
win hour E5 C5 A3 and then we often have
a trade this position is incredibly well
studied and again you have this kind of
situation where white is a pawn chain
and black is attacking either the base
of it or the middle of it with its pawns
and pieces
okay in the game continuation it's a
much inferior version for black because
this Knight is placed on a horrible
square and black has lost the tempo
playing C6 and C5
so Queen C7 I think is decent we got our
Bishop out to D3
E6 F4 I think is pretty sensible I think
our opponent played sensibly for a while
G6 pretty normal move we got our night
out
they got their night out
we brought our Bishop out the Knight
went to F5 and you want to avoid taking
on F5 prematurely I don't like the idea
of giving up the light squared Bishop
until it sort of absolutely necessary
you can play the move Bishop takes F5 at
any moment so rushing a move like that
is just completely senseless and the
bishop on D3 is quite a nicely placed
piece
so does C4 not benefit black I think C4
might even be the best way for black to
handle this position
I actually think that with the light
squares closed down this move makes a
lot more sense
because a position like this is quite
bad for black first of all because of
what I pointed out earlier the fact that
a lot of the dark squares on the king
side are quite weak and we can bring our
Bishop to H4 but the second reason is
that white actually holds a lot of the
cards on the queen side A lot of people
are afraid of this type of attack but
it's not very dangerous when you don't
have your pieces to support the pawn
storm
so like black can bring the pawn to B4
big deal what is black actually
threatening not really
nothing really because C3 is nicely
protected and we can already start
trying to Checkmate black on the other
side of the board with Queen H5 a
devastating threat
and you can see how good this Knight is
H6 by the way there's 96 a worthy
pattern to know this is mate
so no matter what black does on the
queen side our play on the king side is
going to be superior
so that's just one example of why C4 is
not very effective you can of course
also drop the bishop back and again
after B5 you Castle
and if black plays before this could
actually benefit white I would even
consider taking on B4 and bringing the
Knight out because the pawn on D4 is so
well protected by the minor pieces and
the queen that we can afford to give up
its support in service of a better
developing Square for the night later on
you could also play B3 and work on
opening the queen side so Hass always
says that the side that controls the
pawn breaks usually has the advantage
and in this case even though it may
appear the black has a nice Pawn chain
black has no Pawn breaks white is the
one who can push pawns on both sides of
the board and essentially open up the
position whenever he pleases to do that
that's a lot of words but hopefully that
explanation made sense
so C4 might have been the way for black
to play of course black definitely in
the game regretted not playing C4
because we ended up being the ones to
play C4
so we've got our pieces out and I think
Queen B6 is really the beginning of the
end I think after we played C4
Black's position completely evaporates
so probably in retrospect black should
have in fact played C4 and again we can
take on ff5 and a very good move here is
actually to play A4 and prevent black
from playing B5 altogether
then we can play our old idea Bishop H4
and carve out the dark squares on the
king side black has just no active
prospects here at all or immediately
Bishop H4 also makes a lot of sense this
is the engine recommendation
so this type of position
is horrible because this other night is
coming out to G5 a very powerful Outpost
and again although black has more space
on the queen side white is the one who
holds the main Pawn break which is the
move B3 to open up potentially even the
C file or the a file
so
C4 was maybe the Lesser evil and I want
to show you
my inspiration for the move C4 because I
came across a game quite recently that I
thought was pretty sick
it's played in the French championship
all right so this is mvl against the
grave degrave is a former French
Champion very strong Grand Master I've
played him multiple times
let me replay the first moves really
really quickly
so this was the Karo Khan I'm gonna skip
the theory the theory is not that
interesting but you can recognize the
structure and the critical position was
reached in this position
so black has this very typical French
type pressure on D4 and it actually
seems like black has more attackers on
D4 than white could even hypothetically
have Defenders which is true but watch
what MBL does he plays this seemingly
unconcerned move Knight D2 now like what
what the hell is he doing is closing
down his bishop and the grave just takes
on D4 and you might imagine that white
has misplayed the opening right White's
lost the main Center Pawn
what does MBL come up with in this
position it's a brilliant sequence turns
out the black's pieces are so
undeveloped that if white can find any
way to rip open the center White's just
going to have tremendous attacking
potential it's too early for Knight
takes G6 because you reach a dead end
you don't have enough pieces in the
attack
as tempting as it is to sack on G6 it's
premature you just you don't have
Firepower you have one piece at most C4
is correct
and VL plays C4
and he puts another attacker on the D5
Pawn black has to give away the C4
Square for White's Knight but the
brilliant move comes after Queen C7 it
does still look like black is more or
less holding on but in fact this is
already the beginning of the end The
Rook is x-raying the king
so you might be very tempted by Knight
D6 Chuck but this while an interesting
Pawn sacrifice doesn't seem to produce
anything concrete but how do we set it
up
we set it up with Knight to D5 very nice
sacking the Knight and if what black
takes the Knight D6 is devastating
because here it's a discover check and
why when's the queen
and if King E7 then Bishop G5
and Black's King is driven out and
checkmated
then the queen gets out there's this
very beautiful mate
but these lines are ridiculously
one-sided if F6 then white takes it and
drops the bishop back to F4 winning the
queen
so mvl could not or degrave didn't take
it but that allowed the Knight to
infiltrate B6 then the bishop came out
and this game lasts like three more
moves mvl brings all of his pieces out
and degrave resigned in this position
without awaiting White's next move
which I think is Knight takes D7
then it takes E3 and Bishop takes G6
winning all of the pieces on the board
so that's how one side of this game was
and how powerful these C4 ideas can be
okay so now let's go back to the
speedrun game
and C4 is as I refer to it one type of
category of plans in closed positions
which is just to reopen the position
the other category is to keep the center
closed and kind of worm your way around
the center and play on the flanks
this is kind of category one and C4 is
just incredibly powerful the engine
confirms it by the way this is crushing
Queen takes B2 we play CD we play Bishop
F5 and we play DC just completing our
plan maybe not the best way to play in
fact if you run this into an engine the
engine will often give these sort of
slow moves these weirdly slow moves so
here for instance the recommendation is
A4 which actually crossed my mind the
idea is to play A5 and cut off the
Queen's Escape Route
and if CD then you can play Bishop F5
and then CD
and in this position even Knight takes
D4 is crushing because the queen is
suddenly in a lot of trouble the
knight's getting into B5
so it's kind of a move that grabs space
it's almost a waiting move because black
literally has no good way to resolve the
central tension
and in the event of a trade like this
white brings the other night out to F3
this Pawn on A4 can act as a very nice
little push for the attack
yeah it's like plus two at this moment
it's like plus two
so we decided on a more primitive
approach just sort of fully opening the
center
and I will admit that after Bishop D4
Queen A3 E6 there was a move that I had
missed from a distance and this was
literally the only move for black to
play this is the move F6 this was forced
black had to keep the center as closed
as possible because after Rook G8 there
is nothing left to talk about this is
just absolute and total devastation
but if blackhead played F6 despite the
sort of flimsy appearance of Black's
position it's not easy for us to
actually crash through in fact I think
that white needs to be quite careful
here not to be worse
I like the look of the move Knight to H4
attacking F5
and if Bishop takes E6 then we can sneak
the Knight into G6 exploiting some of
the weak squares on the king side
to chip away at Black's defensive
Construction
and then we can play Knight E7 and then
we can bring the king out then we
actually have this move Queen to F3
incredibly strong move
with the idea of the Intermezzo on C5
so
this is all very very hard to defend but
if you flip on the engine it gives some
sort of weird engine move Queen D3
Bishop drops back
94. I mean things do get pretty messy
here
ultimately you get some sort of a
Liquidation in an end game and white is
slightly better
but black holds on with Bishop takes C6
so F6 believe it or not it does appear
and somebody should run the engine here
at a higher depth to find out the truth
but F6 might have kept black very much
in the game position might be
objectively about equal
so you could say that
the strategy that we started with Bishop
takes F5 was a small was maybe not a big
mistake but a small mistake
apparently here we also could have
played a move like Rook to B1
sacking a second pawn and now Queen C1
another typical engine idea
and now Rook A1 traps the queen
so the idea again is to play against
Black's Queen force it back but now we
can play DC that's the other reason we
put the queen on C1 to protect the C5
Pawn so I think it's a good idea to
analyze with engines in these types of
positions because you get a better sense
of really cool ideas that are available
that you could apply at a later point
so some people were suggesting E6 and I
think it is an interesting Pawn sack if
you follow it up with rookie one just
attacking E6 and trying to open up the
e-file which is one of the biggest
things that white can do for his attack
but I wasn't totally sure after Knight
F6 the pawn is defended but now you also
get the juicy E5 Square so definitely
this would be an excellent way for white
to play here there's a ridiculous tactic
Knight DC4
and after the trade the queen is trapped
because if Queen before then Rogue B1
Queen C3 Rook V3 traps the queen
and if Queen B5 there is a fork
and if Queen C3 there's the quiet well
Rook C1
rugby one and Rogue B3 traps the queen
so just an assortment of ridiculous
ideas black actually has to go Queen B5
here
and then take on D6 with the Knight and
black gets three pieces for the queen
but white should still be better because
all of Black's pieces are totally
discombobulated and the King side is
quite weak
so
E6 was a very interesting alternative
just sacking the pawn and opening up the
center an idea that you do see in a lot
of different openings
in the perk you see that often
in the program modern in the bishop C4
lines there's a lot of lines here that
and I'm giving you just an abstraction
where like you you know you drive the
pawn up to East I guess this is not a
sacrifice but it's the same type of idea
you're just blasting open the center
you're throwing the grenade in and then
you're picking it up later in many cases
um in any case
our opponent made a grave error with
Rook to G8 this just served us up with a
very straightforward way to get the king
into the open with all of our pieces
participating
if King E8 here then I would have taken
and now I like the look of a quiet move
like Rook a to C1 just bringing another
piece into the attack as I had discussed
earlier
and now for example Queen F7 is already
winning because you have the additional
check on C6
and it takes and now takes that's the
beauty of putting a rook on C1 you never
know when it's going to serve you well
but it's never going to hurt to bring
another piece into the attack
this was nominally more resilient I
think here the game is largely over
and our opponent did resign what I
thought was a little bit prematurely but
the position is just disgusting
and as I had shown after Bishop D7 I
think the simplest is to go Rook ac-1
and then to play a move like Knight to
G6 or even without Rook AC one you could
just go Knight G6 straight away
and the game is over
the game is over because everything is
hanging
black has no ability to defend anything
this is just Checkmate I mean just look
at this position literally we're
attacking everything we can go Rook B1
we can go rookie one
there's many ways to win but these types
of moves which just pick off a ton of
material are oftentimes the most
clinical and the least risky
so you could dig around here on your own
if you want a better kind of sense of
why this is as lost as as it is but you
should just understand that it's not
even the threat of Checkmate white is
not threatening Checkmate here it's just
that the general nature of Black's
pieces makes the position totally
indefensible
okay so another successful fantasy
outing
very nice we're building up quite a
couple
quite a few nice games in the fantasy
hope you enjoyed these I'm also losing
my voice I hope you enjoyed these games
hope you enjoyed the speed run today and
hopefully see you tomorrow for title
Tuesday bye
[Music]